[Música]
y llegamos directo a china con nuestro
corresponsal adrián foncillas para
hablar con él de las inundaciones que
afectan gravemente al sur de ese país un
fenómeno que también ha golpeado con
fuerza a países como india y bangladesh
adrián los saludos ya muy buena noche
para usted le pregunto cuáles son las
zonas más afectadas del país y cuál es
la situación allí
la zona más castigada es el sureste del
país las policías de cuando ya ni cuando
sí que ha sufrido las las lluvias más
copiosas en décadas hay 85 ríos que
registran niveles de agua más que
preocupantes y en varias zonas ha
decretado la máxima alerta denuncia de
inundaciones son ya medio millón de
desplazados especialmente los que viven
en casas bajas situadas en los márgenes
de los ríos en la provincia de guandong
que es la antigua cantón han quedado
dañadas casi 2.000 viviendas en la
factura de los destrozos supera los
350 millones de dólares y buján donde es
además el epicentro de la fábrica global
y muchas conexiones han quedado
afectadas por lo que inquieta el efecto
en las cadenas de suministro nacionales
y también internacionales no es
previsible que la situación mejore
pronto porque se espera que las lluvias
se alargan un par de días antes de
dirigirse hacia el norte y hay que
recordar que estas no son las primeras
inundaciones del año en china sino que a
principios de mes en el centro del país
ya otras provocaron 32 muertos ganaron
casi 100.000 hectáreas de cultivo
podrían y también por lo que dice es que
cada vez más son frecuentes estos
fenómenos meteorológicos extremos en ese
país le pregunto a qué se debe y además
cómo está actuando el gobierno ante
estos casos
si las inundaciones no son extrañas en
la temporada del monzón y de hecho china
durante toda su historia ha sufrido
gravísimos desbordamientos como los del
río yangtsé que provocaban mortandades
cíclicas lo nuevo es que las lluvias son
cada vez más frecuentes son mayores y
además en lugares tradicionalmente secos
como el sur del tíbet donde hubo lluvias
torrenciales en abril y no podemos
olvidar que el pasado año en general una
provincia central hubo unas tormentas
que la prensa nacional calificó como las
peores en mil años y que dejaron casi
400 muertos algunos abogados dentro del
metro la razón de estos fenómenos es el
calentamiento global que china es
especialmente frágil por su geografía lo
que explica que el gobierno diera un
viraje rotundo a que el crecimiento
económico de las primeras décadas atrás
tras la apertura que provocó una
tremenda calamidad medioambiental y que
lo cambiara por una fórmula mucho más
ecológica por ejemplo ha hecho grandes
esfuerzos en la reforestación y así se
han evitado aquellas tormentas de arena
que sufríamos frecuentemente en pekín
una década y que junto a la
contaminación pues nos impedía salir de
casa durante diez veces e incluso
durante semanas